trips like these are rare because fuel
is expensive this fishing committee is
from the small village of temp Amba in
the south of lake malawi they control a
protected area where fishing is
prohibited the committee set up the zone
themselves to protect their only source
of income the fish fish numbers are
declining and people are seeing their
livelihoods slip away because wherever
they are allowed to fish people are
going to extreme lengths to get anything
they can bernard Guillot is a chairman
on the committee this is a very good
example this is a mosquito net we are
not allowing the inefficient money to
use this type of a net because I didn't
see the size of a mesh even the egg of
an a fish cannot pass through so we
don't allow them to use this type of a
net along the show they can scoop all
the babies so will not have the any fish
for using in the future
protecting the zone is no easy feat it
lies between two villages that are
expanding so food demand is also growing
even children have to go out and provide
for the family
[Music]
this is Chambal the chumbo a type of
perch is the most important species to
these fishermen then awesome day I'm
Wendy the Jumbo that the children caught
are very small they didn't use forbidden
methods but they're harming the lake all
the same because these fish could have
spawned if they had grown up and then
there would have been more jumbo Lake
Malawi has a rich biodiversity around
700 species of fish are found only here
and just around half of them have ever
been scientifically recorded around the
shore you mostly find in buna a native
species of cichlid that are sold around
the world for aquariums
the village of chimp Amba is in the
middle of Lake Malawi National Park it
shouldn't look like this but where can
they go when there are so few fish left
elsewhere there are around 18 thousand
people living in the National Park
almost ten times the number 25 years ago
fish is a staple here and many people
can barely afford it anymore the place
is deader than before as you can see we
walk around it to find the place where
they are selling some fish like this
it's only this the home saga because the
catchment now is very low garbage is
also a big problem here there isn't a
functional disposal system almost
everything ends up in the water but
things are changing local communities
have joined forces with the managers of
a guest Lodge in the nearby town of Cape
McClure to clean the place up the malawi
military even sent a diving unit to help
the soldiers mainly collect plastic
trash it's everywhere water and land so
it's dangerous for humans as well as
fish
kans ripped up nets old pipes broken
dishes there's all manner of garbage at
the bottom of the lake
Kenneth McKay is the founder of Malawian
environment organization he'd Lake
Malawi National Park is a UNESCO World
Heritage Site and it is been threatened
with being delisted because the feeling
was that perhaps it wasn't mean KITT
before as it should the people are out
today National Parks is here Department
of Culture and all the Millau ins are
showing how important this is to them to
keep it clean to keep it managed to stop
any overfishing after just a few hours a
pile of garbage is collected from the
beach and the water it will now be
disposed of responsibly in the evening
the fishing fleet of chimp Amba heads
back out onto the lake they'll be out
there all night hoping for a good haul
but there are just too many fishermen
and not enough fish their hope continues
to dwindle along with the unique
diversity of Lake Malawi